une lettre pour les élus de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on a mis une adresse internet où les
élus peuvent nous répondait même nous
habite et qui le souhaitent
posté à l'occasion de la première marche
pour le climat à saint quentin en
yvelines
elle était organisée par un collectif de
48 associations locales 60 70 % des
actions se font au niveau local
donc c'est au niveau local qu'il faut
agir en premier
voilà donc c'est très important que les
saint quentinois se mobilisent et les
yvelinois là c'est une marche des
yvelines
cette marche était prévue au lendemain
de la deuxième grève mondial des jeunes
partis de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines avec près de 300 manifestants
selon les organisateurs d'une marche
c'est pas c'est parce qu'il va ramasser
les déchets ou directement en fait c'est
plus quelque chose qui va sensibiliser
les gens qui ont ils passé quelque chose
qui prend de l'importance
et c'est grâce avec ce genre
d'évènements pompeux comment dire que
recruter les gens pour faire toutes les
autres actions
il faut aussi préserver tout ce qui a
comme comme verdure encore autour de
nous comme culture cci nos pc un peu une
opération survie maintenant on a des
enfants on aimerait qui grandit dans une
sur une belle plein air elle la
prochaine marche devrait avoir lieu à
versailles à l'occasion du sommet de
l'onu le 23 septembre